hi thank you for joining today i'd like
to introduce myself i'm cindy willems
gibson i'm the quality assurance manager
here at green seal cannabis company
we are a health canada approved licensed
producer in stratford ontario canada
and i wanted to take this opportunity to
talk to you about
managing mold and bacteria in cannabis
we'll start today by
talking a bit about the growing process
and um and then we'll break
break down some of the economic
tradeoffs
so the motivation for this uh topic was
basically that mold is perhaps the
biggest risk during cultivation of
cannabis
it can slash the value of your crop
literally overnight
if you have full-blown mold across your
crop you are not going to be able to
salvage any of it
there's always important compromises
between cost so
money time space and reducing that risk
so we'll talk about
some of those so we're also going to
talk a little bit about some of the key
monitoring points that we put into place
here they have to be identified to
ensure that that risk is reduced
so the basics basically
we have to choose disease-resistant
strains so there's a tray of clones
there
those clones have to be taken from a
healthy mom plant
and those new things together help
ensure that the next crop is going to be
healthy this is one of our rooms where
we actually take those clones so you'll
see that it's uh
a lot of very cleanable equipment the
room itself looks fairly clean
those trays that you see in the back
there they're all cleaned out before
they actually put plants in them
so there's a lot of different things
that we do to try and avoid
mold in the environment as well as on
the plants
um airflow so airflow is very very
important especially in the flower
spaces
um that airflow helps to make sure that
we don't have any hot spots where we
have higher humidity or
temperature
uh temperature and humidity so we the
plants like to be around
25 to 30 degrees celsius or 77 to 86
degrees fahrenheit
and then we usually keep the humidity
somewhere between
55 and 60 percent the biggest problem is
that with cannabis
that those plants and molds like to be
at that same temperature humidity so
we try to keep things a little bit on
the dryer side and keep that good
airflow to make sure that we don't get
any of those like i called them before
hot spots
uh one of the other things about
cannabis is that um to go into a flower
cycle
they um they need a dark and light
period
so because of that um that timing uh
when the lights first
go out it basically the temperature of
the leaf
pulls off very quickly and that
increases the dew point
on the leaf and then basically we could
have condensation on that leaf which
increases the moisture and therefore the
potential for mold
so a lot of times what we do is we turn
off
some of the lights about 15 minutes
early and then we turn off more of the
light so that it's not such a drastic
temperature change
and we also change our airflow a little
bit around that time just to make sure
that we're
managing that
you'll see here the bottom of these
plants are pruned right up
i don't know how closely you can see
that but there's a bunch of nodes at the
bottom
that are all cut off we do that on
purpose to make sure that we can get
good airflow underneath the plants as
well and we
remove some of those large leaves on the
bottom that strip the airflow
air handling is another way that we
manage mold in our rooms
um so we do have some fresh air that
comes in a very small amount the rest of
the air is recirculated
specifically from each room it comes
back into the same room
but we do have filters on there
and we also have uv lights so the uv
lights will actually kill spores that
are in
the air in the ductwork
okay i brought cleaning up again so i'm
going to talk a lot about cleaning
because we do a lot of cleaning
um basically you'll see the first ones
in green the second one's in blue the
reason that i did that is more
internally
we color code here so anything green in
our facility
is more in the grow spaces anything
that's blue
is what we call post harvest so it's
after the plant's been cut down and
those areas we treat more like
food handling area
and then uh cross-contamination so we do
whoops sorry about that available water
moisture and time
so one of the things that we have to do
a lot of
in the post-harvest areas is that we
have to make sure that we manage
the moisture and the temperature the
time that it takes to dry
though um we'll talk a little bit more
about that later on
now i'm at cross contamination so cross
contamination
every day we've got a crew that's always
going around
cleaning handles doorknobs light
switches
equipment anything that could
potentially cross contaminate from one
area to another
and then i just threw this up here um
again we'll talk a little bit more
about the inspection points later but at
every one of those stages
we have a lot of different inspection
points so we're monitoring
temperature humidity we're monitoring
airflow we're monitoring
the cleaning of all the equipment the
cleaning of the rose
that the pruning was done the plant
health was done there's a lot of
different checks and balances that go on
during the entire process
okay so this next one is uh you'll see
our master grower there that's chad
um he's the one that manages all the
plants out in our
in our grow spaces um so
pre-harvest quality vegetative flour and
harvest
we need to start with that clean product
that clean area prior to repopulating
the space
it has to be free of debris so every day
we've got people out there cleaning up
soil leaf litter
we don't have many weeds in here but
occasionally one pops up we do use the
soilless mix
um we make sure that all the garbage
containers in the rooms are covered at
all times so that if there was something
that went in there it can't come back
out
they're emptied at the end of the day
every single day we make sure that we've
got those really healthy plants in there
and if we keep that low micro on the
plants it helps us later on down the
line
so as i mentioned before we clean at
that post harvest stage we clean
everything to like a food grade standard
so we harvest into those clean buckets
and we ensure that any foreign material
so
like the soilless mix we put trellis on
our plants
we have beneficial bug packs that are in
there we make sure that none of that
gets into the post-harvest process
so um one other thing to note that in
this
whole plant health process i want to
talk economics
just dedicated to plant health for one
crop
like pruning removing those dead leaves
tidying cleaning the grow areas and
everything
we dedicate about 3 500 in labor hours
for every 40 kilo lot
so it can be pretty significant but it's
obviously very important too
all right so i've got a little picture
here of botrytis
this is not from our facility taken
directly from the internet
not that it's never happened here
so basically botrytis and powdery mildew
are two of the
biggest concerns that we're worried
about for mold um
botrytis once we get it basically that
piece of the plant has to be taken right
out of the facility like it's just
snipped right off and removed powdery
mildew
we can do a few things in house we don't
use pesticides here
but we do use occasionally something
like
milstop which is basically just baking
soda and water
that changes the ph of the leaf and it
helps the plant to
to not grow powdery mildew
we also use sulfur so
burning sulfur at night will help to
kill that powdery mildew uh
problem is is that the sulfites can
become an allergen
so we have to be really careful with
that one as well
we do use uv on the line every day so
not every day but several times a week
so we run uv
across the plants about one to two
seconds will stop the spores from
growing
so it's just those little vegetative
spores so they don't put spores into the
air it doesn't actually
kill the mold that's on the plant
and we also will use the uv in between
crops
so once we've cleaned everything down we
can do a 30 second pass on there and
that will actually kill spores
in between we can't do that on the
plants because it will actually kill the
plants
so basically um i go back to this one
this botrytis if we lost a crop to
botrytis
um or even powdery milk we could
essentially be looking at upwards of
like 160
000 for one lot that we lose in revenue
and then we also lose all the
the resources that were put into it so
it's a pretty significant
uh we definitely do not want to lose a
crop to that
and again the cleaner the product is
here the cleaner it will be at the end
so we try to avoid any type of mold in
this process at all if we can
uh this is just an example so after we
harvest the plants
i go in my background is in food so
i end up doing a food style setup here
which
seems to work very well
basically in the processing room we
clean the area
prior to populating the space and again
there's all kinds of monitoring that's
done
uh what you see on the screen there is
an atp analyzer
so once we're done cleaning we'll come
around and we just swab for any
biological residue
our guys if you know anything about
cannabis 420 is like the golden number
and uh we use that here as our
release criteria for atp and the guys
get a big kick out of it and
you know at least it's for them they
they aim to get below that
420 and they're you know it's fun for
them anyway it keeps them cleaning
um so then we'll move immediately after
we've
uh processed it we move immediately to
clean drying screens so we have
a team again that's always cleaning
about a quarter of our staff our
production staff is actually dedicated
100
just cleaning and turning over rooms so
um that alone that reduces
the uh the risk a little bit so we put
it onto
clean drying screens and then those
screens they're tossed every once in a
while
and we just get make sure that we get
the airflow on there
okay so um i've got two different things
here we used to do what they call
a dry trim we now do a wet trim
um there's some pros and cons to that i
can talk a little bit to that in a
second but
dry trim basically means that you hang
the plants up first
you let them dry to a certain moisture
and then you trim them and a wet trim
means that you harvest the plants
you trim them right away get all that
excess leaf off
and then you dry them so
basically we have to remove the moisture
from the flower in a controlled manner
that's the biggest thing
so that room is very very important
costs a little bit to set up in the
beginning but the payoff is definitely
there
you need the ability to fully control
the room independently
you have to have more than enough
dehumidification ability which we
learned
as our crops got bigger we realized that
maybe we couldn't keep up so
we made some significant adjustments
back there which are really really
helping
and all our new rooms are set up that
way and it's working great
um we must have humidity control not
just dehumidification on the product
because with cannabis if you can dry it
quickly and it makes a
harsh product um you need to have that
room temperature controlled you need to
have good air flow
and we actually keep it very dark during
the process
though you need to be able to make sure
that the lights are off
all right so this is just an example of
the differences that we found during our
hang dry
um and our wet trim so
a couple things here pro wet trim
less space was taken up so when you hang
all those plants up
it takes up a significant amount of
space because you have all that extra
biomass in there
if you wet brim it actually takes up a
lot less space and there's a lot less
moisture in the room to dry out because
you don't have all those stalks and
stems
we also believe that this helps to
reduce the potential for mold growth
just because you have more control and
there's less biomass
um less trichomes taken off the plant
so um in cannabis the thc trichomes that
are on there
you can actually knock them off during a
dry trim and it ends up in like the
byproduct rather than on the flower
so we found here that if you wet trim it
maintains some of those trichomes and
you have a higher thc in your end
product
some things that we have found is that
with a wet trim it takes more cleaning
there's a lot more residue left on the
product when they're done
it takes longer to turn the room over
and we need a lot
more production stuff for a wet trim all
at the same time
so the biggest problem with this is that
we can't we have a big spike in labor
for those days
but we can't sketch anything else on
those days um
we even have to take back like
office staff to help because it's just
too much all at one time
so um we're we've worked through that
now
but it's uh it can be a struggle so
learning
and of course you don't want to bring
back people that don't know
how to handle the product because again
cross-contamination
lots of training involved so we gotta
make sure that we have the right people
doing the right job
okay this is just a little graph of some
of the timing for the initial dry
basically whether you do a dry trim or a
wet trim
you get that same sort of a curve but
we're starting upwards of 70 percent
moisture and we need to get that down
very very quickly
in the first day so um first day
or two days we don't want to have that
higher moisture for too long a time
because then it gives the
mold more time for growth so um
on the other side of that the flip side
if you dry it too quickly
you can get this harsh product so um
a longer cure so basically there's
initial dry
and then there's a curing process that
initial dry
we usually do in about two days we bring
it down to 30
we put it into a closed bucket bag
whatever seal it up for six hours we
take it back out of that bag and that
just
evens out the moisture throughout the
whole lot
put it back on drying racks bring the
moisture down a little bit more
we make sure the available water is less
than about
0.56 and then that makes sure that
we've got minimal potential for mold
growth and then we hold it
at that moisture for another
seven to ten days roughly
now this is the curing so what you see
there is a
sea vault you can use any kind of bucket
to
keep that moisture in um but basically
this is what i was just talking about
that 30 moisture we do this bucket
sweat it doesn't sound very appealing
but that's but what it does it pulls the
moisture out of the
stems in the middle and brings it to the
side so that we can dry it more evenly
we put it back on those drying screens
we bring it under that 0.6
available water and then we bring it
down to around a 12 percent moisture
all right and then we terminology we
burp
the uh the bins every day uh while it's
curing
and that just off-gasses and just make
sure that the product's uh
maintaining a good even moisture
we check the moisture every day we uh
sometimes we'll check terpenes and like
that as well
basically it does we do do a lot of
tests
uh during this period to make sure that
we're monitoring that moisture
and available water as tightly as we can
there's a few things that we can do if
we want to
increase the moisture there's a boveda
pack there there's bavita integra
there's a lot of different types of
packs that
will adjust the moisture to bring it up
or we can spread it out on drying racks
again and bring the moisture down
we use hundreds hundreds of grams
of moisture of flour for moisture tests
so i'll talk to that again in a second
basically we need consistent repeatable
reproducible
um results in order to get those
that quality
all right so this is just nothing to do
with cannabis but we apply food curing
and aging science to cannabis
so that's why we need to understand the
available water and the moisture
we need to understand what is a good
available water and moisture for
cannabis and
another economic trade-off here so 10
moisture product loss and 13 could be
close to mold growth
so we try to keep it in that
height window basically
for every one percent difference in one
batch
it's about a sixteen hundred dollar
difference so if we package our product
at twelve percent versus 11
that's give away right
so this is basically why we cure the
product
just like meat or cheese or tobacco or
anything earring brings out the aromas
and the flavors and it accentuates those
natural terpenes
okay so some of the testing that we do
we use
a rototronic available water meter and
we use
a at53 method toledo moisture analyzer
pretty basic equipment the nice thing
about the available water is that it's a
simple internal test
anybody on the line can do it it's
non-destructive
so it's it's fairly quick it's a good
indicator for mold growth
again taken from the food industry 0.6
seems to be around
where whether it's you know obviously
it's different for different things but
0.6 seems to be where herbs and stuff
like that are good
to avoid mold growth
and it's a really quick test so um
one of the things about that is
especially when the moisture is really
really high
it might only take seven or eight
minutes to get the available water but
if we were to run the moisture test on
it
it might take 45 minutes to an hour
so the moisture analyzer it's also a
simple internal test
we've trained lots of people here how to
do it it's a destructive test
but it is industry standard so um
definitely that's what we use when we're
finally releasing our product
um this is our measurement for giveaway
so
it tells us basically if we're going to
save that sixteen hundred dollars or
thirty two hundred dollars or if we're
going to give it away
um and then it takes much longer as i
was mentioning if the flower is wet or
fresh
so it can take a significantly long time
but the nice thing about it is basically
you
prep it you put it in there you walk
away and you come back for a result so
it's at least not that bad
but we do use hundreds of grams of
product in testing
again just to make sure that we're
monitoring our our moisture
and available water uh which again could
be
hundreds even thousands of dollars
we do take for every batch that we
produce
we do actually have somebody that takes
about eight
hours worth of testing so um just for
moisture
so you know it can add up significantly
at the end of the day all this helps to
ensure a quality product that we can be
proud to put the green seal of approval
on
so just so that we can review quickly um
summary of the trade-offs there's a
significant cost of labor hours
just for cleaning and and maintaining
plant health
but it reduces the chance of mold the
dollar value of the product at 10
versus thirteen percent can be
significantly different so it's uh
value added to do all that extra testing
the cost of testing in-house and
external
adds up but as i just mentioned there's
a reason we do it
um the loss of product due to mold is
significant
so this is why we put so much
preventative
in place um and the consumer perception
so quality of the product
not too dry haste metal harsh product is
uh
very very important
so thank you i appreciate your time
if you do want to reach out to green
seal cannabis our website is there at
the bottom of the page
if you have any specific questions that
you wanted to ask you can send it to
info
greensealcannabis.com or you can send it
directly to me at my email
all right thank you so much again take
care